Jocko as a leader, at what point am I allowed to go to others and say,
I need you because I recognize I'm not capable of pushing toward forward on my
own,
or should that be an instance where I need to take a step back and apply more
discipline to my life and find a way to push forward by myself? Okay.
You are allowed to say that to your team member immediately that you need them.
Absolutely. If you,
of course you need your team because if he didn't need your team,
why would they be there? If you can do everything yourself,
then you don't have a team, right? You just do everything yourself.
So while you of course should be working harder,
you should be applying discipline as a leader.
It's your job to actually lead things and to let other people support and make
things happen. And there's nothing wrong with that.
And also you don't want to be stuck in the weeds doing minute things. So
it,
if you're not capable, I think what might be holding this individual back,
there's two things.
Number one is I feel like I should take extreme ownership of everything.
I feel like I should just do everything myself.
That is not what extreme ownership is.
Extreme ownership isn't doing everything yourself.
And also what can come into play is your ego because you don't want to ask
people for help and that's not a good sign.
There's nothing wrong with asking people for help if you need it. In fact,
that's the humble thing to do. Hey, echo,
I don't know how to quite finish out this. Uh, you know,
this thing of this project and working out. Can you give me a hand with this?
I don't know how to work a video recorder. Can you show me how to do that?
Right? Whatever. Um, so, so there's no problem with that. You're allowed to ask.
You can, you can say that immediately. In fact,
your team should feel that you are counting on them and relying on them.
They should know that. And then put your ego aside, ask for help.
No problem. That doesn't mean you're giving away.
That doesn't mean you're not taking ownership.
That doesn't mean you're not applying discipline.
It means you're working as a team together to accomplish mission. Again,
if a t if a mission is so easily that you can accomplish it yourself,
you don't need a team, why do you have them?
If you can do it all yourself just by applying discipline. Cool.
You don't need anyone else if you're your,
but your mission should be larger than one human being could accomplish.
So that's why you have other people on board to help you out. Yeah, no problem.
You know, like I always think when, when that happened,
we made it out of that question. Go ahead. No, but you know,
like let's say it's like something that's just a pain in the ass and you don't
really need help, but you just don't want to do it by yourself. Oh, okay.
What I'm saying then? Yeah, then you got to do that by yourself. Oh yeah.
So that's kind of where this is coming from ultimately, because it's like,
I'm not saying that if you're the,
if you're,
if you have a position in a company where you shouldn't be doing some sort of
task because it's not financially efficient to have,
you know,
a person that's making $150,000 a year doing a task that someone that's making
$10 hour should it be doing [inaudible] so, so you shouldn't do that.
That's not what I'm advocating. And the company won't, won't be doing well.
Yeah.
If you're paying people $150,000 a year that you could get someone to do for $10
an hour. I'm not saying that, so don't get me wrong. Yeah.
But that's why we have a team so that you can focus on going forward and
whatever it is you need to be focused on and somebody that's below you in the
chain of command,
that's a member of your team that's getting paid $10 an hour can do some of the
stuff that you need them to do.
Yeah. Yeah. And the question actually is,
is really clear because it's because quote unquote,
because I recognize I'm not capable of pushing you. You know, it's kind of like,
ah, it's obvious to you that you need help. It's not that you're, you know,
raking leaves and I don't want to do this all by myself, so hey, you know,
you tell your brother, come help me. It's not that it's different.
Yeah.
And if you need to get the leaves raked and you need them done by Monday so you
can get them in the bags so that the dump truck can come and take the leaves
away and you can't physically get it done, then you say to your brother, Hey,
can you give me a hand?
I need to get these done tonight before the sun goes down.
I'm not gonna be able to make it in time. Can you give me a hand? Yeah.
Your brother says, absolutely. Got Your back.